hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here oh and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is our review of all most
humans episode 7 & 8 yeah yeah one Simon
Says and you are you are here yes which
you you let me know that you are here
was originally supposed to be the second
i believe it was I think that's why a
second or third one of the early ones
because starts off with him in anger
management which if you do watch it now
does seem a little bit interesting like
a wise nagar management now but if it
played after the first episode when he
throws his MX unit out the you know out
of the car it makes more sense ways and
anger management but yeah so of the two
episodes i actually liked Simon Says
more than I did you are here Simon Says
is though yeah the one with the little
uh what's his face bar right yeah
beginning yeah yeah um data yeah yeah
gate I lieutenant Gaeta it was great
because that was one where Dorian was a
little bit off his rocker yeah that one
no one was funny it was yeah I like that
I like that Dorian was yeah because he
couldn't get the charge that I needed
and that laws funny banter between him
and yeah and Kennex yeah uh yeah so I
thought even though we was an episodic
I'm they're both episodic sure so yeah
right I thought that one got my
attention more sure it's it's nothing
new you know we've seen before this type
of her like saw like thing where
someone's trapped and they forced to do
all this stuff right but I was
interested in and also I think it helped
that in the beginning they got this guy
and they killed him yeah like he died
yeah yeah like they didn't you know they
they fail yeah they don't mess around
like they actually killed him so like to
let you know that okay all right there's
danger my only people that this episode
is that the guy was trying to get known
and the kept showing his view count he
got to like me like 30,000 I'm like
that's not really that much and you want
to go fire at least a million views to
go by so just kind of funny that actor
also is in a bunch of stuff he was in
prison oh yeah yeah I know his face was
in the dark night he just has one of
those creepy 13 faces even when he
smiles you're like wow he's always
taping every movies in and so they
obviously keep the casting for this
right i mean it's like the show still is
solid but i always think it's a good
show
oh like its hiding no I think it could
be a great show I want to see more like
I think the show still just like playing
it a little safe it's very safe it's not
taking any risk whereas I know as uses
comparison but sleepy hollow I think
takes a lot of chances they do a lot of
weird crazy things this show just kind
of it's a cop show it's a buddy show but
the buddies are so good that it kind of
think the show it elevates a little
higher than other shows because the you
know Doreen and John have such great
chemistry yeah I would like them to
branch out and then we saw you are here
where they briefly mentioned in the
beginning about the whole since in
syndicate right and this is girlfriend
yeah yeah which we still don't know much
about which we haven't really talked to
about rights yeah you think about it
this is the actually the second episode
yeah I'm so stupid err second then it's
like okay what's been going on right
yeah I don't know I yeah I want more
that story I the pilot wasn't perfect
you know I didn't think it was perfect
but I want to see more of that story
definitely yeah I wasn't that thrilled
with the the you are here episodes
episode 8 with the the flying moving
bullet thing yeah that was analogy I
think about the girl I didn't care that
the guy died I was like yeah that's
that's too bad I feel bad for him but
it's like I want to know you know they I
thought for a myth or gonna start
developing every carriage like remember
the first couple episodes the second or
third one second oh no the second ones
the sex bots yeah I'm always down for
that um the third one I he was the
episode with a guy from Game of Thrones
a British guy and far as the caribou how
much for his name but it was kind of
about you know he wanted like tag along
and hang out I thought they were gonna
do like every ops was going to develop
each character they kind of didn't minka
kelly a little bit but they really
haven't gotten back to that yet they're
not developing their supporting cast
very well I don't think in the Simon
Says episode is that the one that Dorian
gets his new home which is inside the
lab with a yeah I want to see but maybe
that's why because this new one you are
here with lesbian sewed too because I
thought maybe we'd see him and the guy
like living together like that but yeah
hanging out like what that looks like
but they never touched on that but I
think that's because it was episode 2
yeah I thought that was a nice denial
yeah that's the problem these episodic
ones it's like
yeah I really like this one or kind of
like this one or as bored with this one
and all right it's kind of that's what
it's doing to me it's like oh this
episode Simon Says I was interested in
this and then you are here not so much
it's a show enjoy watching sure i'll
continue to watch but is not something i
would say i get excited before i'm just
i'm kind of cursing like okay what are
we gonna get this week you're gonna get
an engaging episode or not I don't know
I'm never I'm not I mean I know it's all
about emotion or not pumped about the
show like I don't get like good game of
thrones even like justified's back on
all those shows I'm like oh I guess
watch episode justified watch episode of
Game of Thrones an ape-like I get
excited this show I'm just kind of just
kind of watch it i'm not but i want to
get excited i think it's got a great
cast they got to start doing a bigger
story line now really that's interested
right open up the world cuz if they end
the season just with all episodic
episodes and be like what's the what's
the point of me right and then the next
yeah like I mean why would you even come
back exactly yeah all right all right
guys are you guys watching almost human
stone what are you thinking about each
of the episodes and episodic nature you
can post your comments below on the
website think hero.com make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
think hero pro and post comments there
yeah yeah I also come and check with us
on Twitter we're at think heroes Dennis
and I myself Michael I'm at Griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and make sure
you take our videos and tweet them out
and post post on Facebook and stuff it
helps out a lot
you